estas ocho cartas se ponen boca abajo y
se revuelven son cartas con números del
1 al 8 muy bien luego dices y beatriz
voltea únicamente una carta cuál es la
probabilidad de que obtenga un número
menor a 4 menor a 4
bueno pues todas estas cartas tienen la
misma probabilidad de salir son
igualitas iban a estar boca abajo así
que pues son indistinguibles entre sí y
queremos obtener un número menor a 4 y
cuántos números cumplen que son menores
a 4 serían el 1 el 2 y el 3 el 4 no el 4
no es menor a 4 si dijera menor o igual
entonces si tendríamos que considerarlo
pero como dice menor es estrictamente
menor vale entonces solo son las cartas
con el 1 el 2 y el 3 y bueno eso son las
posibilidades favorables y en total
tenemos 88 cartas de esta forma tenemos
que la respuesta sería 3
3 dividido este 3 viene de que hay 3
cartas favorables menores a 4 dividido
entre la cantidad de cartas totales
entre 8 entonces entre 8 entonces la
probabilidad sería tres octavos vale
vamos a ver si eso está entre las
opciones
ve muy bien siempre es padre cuando lo
que encontramos está en las opciones
entonces la respuesta sería ve la
probabilidad es tres octavos vamos al
siguiente problema
dice la librería un poco más arriba la
librería des acatitlán quiere ver qué
tipo de libros se prestan más
frecuentemente ok y aquí nos ponen un
diagrama circular bien padre entonces
vamos aquí abajo a ver qué nos dice de
acuerdo a la gráfica bueno aquí le
llaman gráfica de acuerdo a la gráfica
circular de arriba y yo creo que tenemos
que elegir la que sea verdadera de estas
opciones bueno pues vamos a ver de
acuerdo a la gráfica circular de arriba
se prestan más libros infantiles que de
romance y ciencia ficción combinados
pues vamos a ver infantiles son los de
los de niños entonces queremos comparar
este 26 por ciento con la combinación de
romance y ciencia ficción romance es 13
por ciento es este de acá es un poco feo
romances este de acá ciencia ficción es
este de acá si sumamos romance con
ciencia ficción es 13 18 cuantos esos 13
más 18
y es 3 y 81 llevamos 11 y 12 y 13 31
entonces saber combinar nuestros dos es
31%
la combinación es de 31% y queremos ver
si se prestan más infantiles que de la
combinación pues no infantiles solo se
prestan 26% y 26% no le gana a 31%
entonces esta opción no es déjame
cambiar de color para checar las demás
ve más de la mitad de los libros que se
prestaron fueron los infantiles
de misterio y de arte combinados pues
vamos a ver los infantiles son 26
bueno lo voy a poner aquí es este de acá
infantiles ministerio que es 20 por
ciento y de arte de arte que es 4 por
ciento entonces 26 por ciento con 4 por
ciento es 30 por ciento y eso hay que
juntarlo con este 20 por ciento de acá
es decir nos queda 50 por ciento la
combinación es 50 por ciento que es
exactamente la mitad de los libros pero
aquí dice más de la mitad más de la
mitad sale y 50 por ciento no es más de
la mitad es justo a la mitad si aquí
dijera la mitad o más entonces sí sería
esta opción pero como estamos
exactamente en la mitad pues eso no es
más de la mitad y por lo tanto ésta
tampoco es vamos ahora
vamos ahora a la se dice más libros de
misterio fueron prestados que de arte y
ciencia ficción combinados entonces
misterio
tenemos que compararlo con arte y
ciencia ficción combinados con arte y
ciencia ficción combinados pues saber de
misterio es 20 por ciento y de arte y
ciencia ficción combinados es 4 + 18 o
sea 22 por ciento y esto no le gana a 20
por ciento entonces ésta tampoco es
debería ser la opción de a menos que nos
hayamos equivocado en algo bobo por ahí
vamos a ver si en efecto lo que dice la
opción d es verdadero más de la mitad de
los libros que se prestaron fueron los
de romance
misterios y ciencia ficción combinados
romance misterios y ciencia ficción
vamos a ver romance misterio
y ciencia ficción vamos a hacer la suma
13 18 eso ya lo habíamos hecho 13 18 es
31 por ciento y con este 20 por ciento
es 51 por ciento hay 51 por ciento si es
más de la mitad ahora si le gana de
adeveras entonces si en efecto más de la
mitad de los libros que se prestaron
fueron los de romance misterio y ciencia
ficción combinados y por lo tanto la
respuesta es d